[Music]
hello welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my
name is Angela lomacang I'm glad that
you've tuned in you are going to be
blessed you know we are on a mission
from the Lord yeah we're on a mission we
have an obligation from the Lord from
Matthew 24
verse4 and it says and this Gospel of
the Kingdom will be preached to the
whole world as a witness and what's
going to happen and then the end will
come I'm so excited looking forward to
that day aren't you I know I am and we
are too well we have a thank you for
your prayers and financial support of
this ministry we appreciate this so much
and today we have Bible questions for
you and if you have a pen and a paper or
your Bible go get it okay you want to
sit down and get it and you're going to
be blessed today but if you have
questions that you would like to send in
you can email them to us by going to
Bible QA
3abn.org
you can send your Instagram message by
going to @
3abn
official wow I'm excited today we have
the sons of thunder sons of thunder
James and John right here with us and we
have five we have uh five minute
questions I believe four minute
questions and one five minute question
so let's introduce our sons of thunder
let's begin with Pastor James welcome
thank you Angie it's good to be here
looking forward to the questions and the
answers amen the word of God okay that's
one of the sons of thunder here's the
other one in front of me hey sweetheart
how you doing that's right James and
John the Lord has something in store for
today and thank you for tuning in this
gives us you know what I like about this
format but just two of us it gives us
chance to break down this rich food
God's word is so concentrated James you
know that that sometimes we just get a
chance to Rapid Fire and people kind of
em huh so we're going to try our best
today to kind of slow it down a little
bit and uh make it palatable and make it
uh uh digestable digestible there you go
thank you so much appreciate it but
James and John amen glad to have you
would you please open with prayer honey
sure loving father gracious God we thank
you for the privilege and opportunity a
great responsibility to open the word of
God to step into this chamber that has
Unlimited Supply furnished by the
inspiration of your Holy Spirit under
the direction of your Almighty wisdom
and so Lord open our minds as humans and
pour into it the understanding that is
needed and so as we answer these
questions we can do so not understanding
that it is us but really it is you amen
we're communicating your word and we
pray that on the other side of this
program there are people whose hearts
are fertile whose minds are willing to
receive what the spirit says to them
today be with our host be with every
aspect of the program and the technical
side but may all the glory go to you in
Christ name amen amen amen okay we are
going to get right into the questions
we're going to start with you James all
right okay here we go this is a quick
question here it is this is from Diana
in Georgia and it says why did David
write so many Psalms asking for
destruction of people that is such a
good question Diana in Georgia thank you
for sending in that question you know
David in the Psalms was
processing his anger and the Bible
instructs us to do this in Ephesians 4
and verse 26 the Bible says there be
angry and sin not Don't Let the Sun Go
Down on your wrath there's three points
here we want to look at first of all God
is actually instructing us to be angry
and that is very unusual because
sometimes we would associate anger with
sin and in a negative context but then
it says the angry and sin not so
apparently this type of anger the Bible
is talking to us about is not sin it's
the opposite of sin in fact not being
angry would actually lead you to sin and
then finally do it before the sun goes
down and this was
David's habit this is what David did he
would process his anger and we see a lot
of that in the Psalms let's just look at
one example Psalm 59 if we open up to
Psalm 59 we're going to find that David
is in a situation where he is running
from Saul and and in his uh angst he is
opening his heart to God Saul has been
treating him unjustly there's no reason
for Saul to be after David trying to
take his life David is a man after God's
Own Heart he is one who's tried to
minister to Saul he was singing Psalms
to him and then Saul picks a spear up
and tries to kill him and goes after him
at his house and David escapes through
the window gets away and begins this
Psalm Psalm 59 he begins with and we're
just going to outline this is helps h e
l PS help me Lord deliver me from my
enemies oh my God defend me from them
that rise up against me so David's anger
the process of his anger always begins
with a call for help he asks God God to
help him and then e he explains his
situation verses three and four for Lo
they wait for my soul my the mighty are
gathered against me he begins to explain
his situation so H is help me deliver me
e is explaining the the situation and
then L he lets out his anger notice what
he says here down in verse 13 consume
them in th wrath consume them that they
me not may not be David does this often
in the Psalms Psalm 59 is one example
there are many others I'll give you one
that you can go through it's Psalm 54
it's a very short Psalm and you'll find
the same outline in there the only thing
that's missing in Psalm 54 is the S
which is going to be surprise so after
David be lets out all of his anger L
then he praises the Lord and we see this
in Psalm 59 and verses 16 and 17 but I
will sing of thy power I will sing aloud
of thy mercy in the morning for thou
Hast been my defense so he's processing
his anger before he goes to sleep he's
asking God to help him he's explaining
his situation he's letting out his anger
and then he's praising the Lord and he
says in the morning when I wake up I'm
just going to praise the Lord because
everything's out of me and then Saul
catches or David uh uh finds Saul in a
cave Saul is pursuing David he ends up
in a cave and David and his men are on
the outside of that cave right Saul
doesn't know it and David's men say to
him just say the word uh David and we'll
put a spear through Saul and we'll take
his life this is an answer to prayer God
has delivered your enemy into his hands
into our hands let's take them out and I
remember the first time I ever read that
and I thought yes yes yes yes I know
right and then David's like no no we're
not going to do this and I was like what
a surprise that's the S what a surp
Christ you see when we process our anger
when we let our anger out when we give
our anger to God we it it dissipates
it's gone and we don't manifest it
toward people we don't sin against
people people may mistreat us but as
long as we process our anger to God as
long as we process our anger responsibly
we won't process it irresponsibly we'll
be able to treat people the way God told
us to treat people that is to turn the
other cheek and to go the extra mile so
this is why we see anger through the
Psalms because David is processing to
God so he doesn't process toward people
that's true and everyone goes through
anger right everyone gets angry but the
Bible says be angry and sin not but you
know he's human in fact the person that
gets angry the most in the Bible is God
oh when he over look the word anger
you're going to see more of the verses
applying to God than anyone else because
God is angry about the Injustice the
unfairness in this world but again he
doesn't process his anger like we we we
humans do he process it the way that
David did that's righteous IND that's
that's right that's right thank you for
that wonderful all right John the other
Thunder okay let's go to your here it is
your four minute
question are there two
Heavens Jesus said he will go and
prepare us a place in heaven yet there
is a heaven on Earth the Bible says
Jesus will come from heaven and live
with us on this Earth Earth I'm new to
church and this is confusing to me I'm
still learning the Bible and scripture
please explain this is Cosby from either
Western Australia or Washington it says
wa in C okay all right well thank you
Cosby appreciate that you began by
asking the question are there two
Heavens no they're actually three
Heavens just to start the question out
in an appropriate way and then I'll
share what those Heavens are and I'll
give you scripture to support that the
first Heaven that the Bible talks about
is where God is you know there was worn
Heaven the devil was kicked out of
heaven but we'll go to that last let me
start with the one that is most close to
us where the birds and the airplanes fly
Genesis 1:20 that's the first so when
you look up and you see wow Heavens are
clear today you're not looking at
planets and solar systems you're looking
right above you is it cloudy is it clear
are there birds do you see planes are
there helicopters and the Bible says in
Genesis 1:20 then God said let the
waters abound with an abundance of
living creatures and let birds fly above
the Earth across the face of the
firmament of the heavens and so when you
go outside today if you're outside
already when you look up you see wow how
beautiful today the birds are out today
but birds don't fly outside of the
hemisphere the ionosphere the osphere
they don't because they could not
breathe there's the heavens where a
human life cannot naturally exist that's
why astronauts they put on all this
apparatus to preserve life outside of
the time of the place where life is
balanced with the ozone the oxygen the
hydrogen and all the different things
that are included there second one then
there are the planets and the Stars uh
David the psalmist writes in Psalm 19
verse one the heavens declare the glory
of God and the firmament shows his handy
works so when you go outside on a
beautiful night like here in Southern
Illinois we have opportunity to do this
some nights my wife says get out the
telescope it's so clear and sometimes we
could just go in the backyard where it's
completely dark and look up and we see
wow look at the stars look and we don't
realize that we're not just looking at
stars but some of those that are great
in the distance are galaxies and places
that just are not reachable by by human
uh methods so that's the second one
where the plan and the stars are and the
third one is where God is revelation
3:12 he who overcomes I will make him a
pillar in the temple of my God and he
shall go out no more I will write on him
the name of my God and the name of the
city of my God the New Jerusalem which
comes down out of Heaven from my God and
I will write on him my new name so the
the third heaven is where the New
Jerusalem is coming from now you
mentioned in your question yet there is
a is there a I don't know if it was a
question or a comment but it seemed like
with the question mark is there a heaven
on Earth no there is no Heaven on Earth
and Heaven will not be on earth the New
Jerusalem will be on earth Revelation 21
verse 1:3 now I saw a new Heaven and a
new Earth for the first Heaven and the
first Earth had passed away and there
was no more sea and when it says passed
away means made new you know as Malachi
talks about one day will the the wicked
will be ashes Under The Souls of our
feet on the day that the Lord does that
so the new Heavens meaning there's not
going to be any flags on the Moon from
Russia or the United States they're not
going to be there and there are not
going to be any traces of sin on this
planet that we have but at the end of
the Thousand Years the Bible says in
John in Revelation
21:2 then I John saw the holy city New
Jerusalem coming down out of Heaven from
God prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband and then we going to have the
privilege as Revelation goes on further
it says in that latter part it says and
God behold the Tabernacle of God is with
men and he will dwell with them and they
shall be his people and God himself will
be with them and be their God so there
are three Heavens Earth is not heaven
but one day the New Jerusalem will be
here on Earth coming down out of Heaven
amen isn't there atmosphere what is that
atmosphere which atmosphere of
troposphere ionosphere hemisphere that's
that's where the birds fly the PLS exist
and I think that goes up to about 90,000
ft but birds don't go up that high and
you know planes don't go up that high
for sure but then outside of that it
comes the place where you need apparatus
to even live matter of fact above 13,000
ft humans need something to preserve
them because you can't breathe easily
above 13,000 yeah you're in a plane
you're at 30,000 and if something goes
wrong you need air at 30,000 that's
right so you're in trouble we can't
exist naturally outside of that and
outside of that is the beautiful Heavens
which we look forward to having one day
James and John will be be up there
flying together
amen not un united either exactly not un
united but we will be United in flying
we'll be United we'll come around for
lunch new Heaven and a new Earth ah
looking forward to that AR you all right
let's keep trusting the Lord he has a
great plan for you
okay all right Pastor James here we
go Jesus ascended to heaven in
ad31 and he ENT the most holy place in
1844 that is very plain and as
Adventists we put a lot of emphasis on
his mediatorial work in the most holy
place
but what did he do in the Holy place for
1,813 years H I do not understand that
part of his ministry please help me
nobody ever talks about this period this
is from Janette in South Africa well
Janette in South Africa that's a great
question and we need to look at that
question according to the Bible Jesus
actually began his mediatorial work in
uh at his Ascension in
ad31 so the reason why perhaps a lot of
us don't talk about that is because we
kind of assume that everyone knows that
what Jesus is doing now was begun in
ad31 and that his transition from the
holy place to the most y place was a
transition to his finalizing that work
of mediation in other words he's in the
final moments or parts of that same work
but that work began in ad31 let's look
at a couple Bible verses the first one
we want to look at is in Hebrews chapter
8 verses 1 and two Paul is speaking here
about the work of Christ in the
Fulfillment of the types of the Old
Testament the sanctuary types the the
priesthood of the Old Testament he says
now the things which we have spoken this
is the susm we have such a high priest
who is set on the right hand of the
Throne of the Majesty in the heavens
verse two Hebrews 8 a minister of the
sanctuary and of the true Tabernacle
which the Lord pitched and not man so
right here in the time of the apostolic
church after Christ's Ascension right in
in the in the time before ad. 100 Paul
is talking about what Christ is doing in
heaven he's saying he is a mediator in
the heavly Sanctuary now we know and the
book of Hebrews teaches as well as the
whole Bible that he's mediating in the
Holy place he's not in the most holy
place because the most holy Place
mediation was the wrapping up of
intercession for the human race and that
wasn't going to take place that was a a
day of atonement or a final day of
judgment the the the antitypical day of
atonement that took place once a year in
the Earthly Sanctuary type and so when
Christ moves from the holy place to the
most holy place we know that his
ministry is almost finished so that
doesn't take place at ad31 at ad31 he
goes to the holy place we have another
Bible verse this one is found in 1 John
2 verse one and John here is talking to
the Believers and he says if any man sin
we have an advocate with the father
Jesus Christ the righteous but then he
goes on and I really love this because
it's very inclusive he says and he is
verse two the propitiation for our sins
and not ours only but also for the sins
of the whole world and so Jesus Christ
is mediating for believers but he's also
mediating for the entire world he's
sending angels and His Holy Spirit to
convict and and to bring to draw people
to him and to help people to realize
he's their savior I know before I was a
personal believer in Jesus Christ he was
drawing me through his work of
intercession and we see the beginning of
this work actually in John chapter 17 it
kind of gives us a taste of his
mediatorial work uh it's understood by
many p uh to be a foretaste of Christ
intercessory Mission uh uh the beginning
of this transition it takes place right
before he dies he's there in the Garden
of Gethsemane he with his disciples and
he begins to pray and intercede for his
disciples he begins to pray and
intercede that they would be one as as
as he and the father are one and so
that's part of the work that Christ is
doing this Prayer Ministry and this is
this of course is based on the Old
Testament types so we talked about that
just a little bit but the Old Testament
types the priest would go into the holy
place every day all through the year
every day and he'd Minister and he'd
make a sacrifice for the sins of the
people but only once a year he would go
from the holy Place into the most holy
place and he would make what was
understood to be the final atonement the
final sacrifice for the sins of all the
people for that year and everyone was to
afflict their souls we are living in the
anti-typical or the Fulfillment of that
day of atonement we see Jesus
transitioning now from the most the holy
place to the most holy place in 1844 and
so the work is really no different in
the sense of mediation in the sense of
sacrifice in the sense of what God is
doing what Christ is doing but the
difference is is he's in the final face
he's closing it up and so we have this
added emphasis of judgment and
investigation in order for him to finish
up the work of sealing God's people so
that when probation closes those that
are just will be just ill and those that
are unjust will be unjust still and
everything will be settled and Jesus can
return that's right now someone may ask
what is the antitypical day of atonement
what is anti-typical okay so you've got
a type in other words uh it's a it's
illustrating something that is not the
reality so uh you've got a type and an
antitype so when we say antitypical
right we're saying this was the typical
this was the Fulfillment of this type of
this of this illustration I'm trying to
think of something that I could use as
an illustration but that's the best I
can do for now my my brain's not uh like
like the Shadow and tie for example the
shadow is for for seeing that I'm if you
follow my shadow that's the typical
right and then if you find me then I'm
the antitypical one leads the other so
the ceremonial system prefigured the
coming works of Christ the shadow in the
reality the shadow in the reality John
Shadow is not who he is exactly it's a
shadow of the reality and the the
Earthly Sanctuary service with the was a
shadow of the reality of Jesus Christ
that's right that's right I like that
antitype type Shadow reality antitype
Shadow okay wonderful you may have just
joined us and you're wondering how can I
send a question in well you can email us
by going to Bible QA at
3abn.org 975 or if you're an
instagrammer you can send an Instagram
by going to @
3abn official okay let's go to our
questions here we go Pastor John oh this
is your five minute question yes here we
go I know the Bible doesn't mention the
Trinity but one time there are people
who say there are three persons in one
God the only person is Jesus God the
father is a spirit the Holy Ghost is a
spirit so who is correct this is from
Mai in Nevada okay well just to kind of
clarify the Bible never mentions the
word Trinity no but the word godhead is
mentioned twice and when you think about
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
this is the topic that I I'd love to do
a seminar on because this has been a
subject of great confusion among many
people that have tried to put Divinity
in the terms of humanity now the Bible
talks about God as being a spirit but
he's not just a spirit in the sense of
spiritual but he also has Dimensions
because in the very beginning in Genesis
the Bible says speaking about the
creation of man let us make man in our
image according to our likeness so God
has a likeness and then we find let us
make man in our image the father and the
son speaking there so we are created in
the image of God it even says that in
the image of God created him male and
female in the image of God he created
them so we had we bore the image of God
in creation before sin marred that image
but when you look in the Bible you see
the you see the father Son and Holy
Spirit All Through the Bible let me give
you some examples and I'll use the New
Testament because sometimes people said
well is it in the New Testament yeah
it's in the New Testament let's look at
the birth of Jesus for an example Luke
1:35 speaking to Mary and the angel
answered and said to her now notice
who's mentioned remember now she's
impregnated with the sea that will
become Christ on Earth yes the holy
spirit will come upon you and the power
of the highest will overshadow you
therefore also that Holy one who is to
be born will be called The Son of God
notice Holy
Spirit the the power of the highest yeah
and the Son of God being born in her all
three are mentioned to their clearly
then you go later into the ministry of
Jesus Christ Matthew 3:1 16-1 17 when he
that is Jesus was baptized had been
baptized Jesus came up immediately from
the water and behold the heavens were
opened and he saw the spirit of God
descending like a dove and lighting upon
him and then verse 17 and suddenly a
voice Came From Heaven saying this is my
beloved Son in whom I'm well pleased
Jesus being baptized the holy spirit in
the form of a Dove and then the father
speaking from Heaven this was not
Ventrilo ventriloquism and some people
say well God was manifested three ways
first he was God then he became Jesus
then he became the spirit that is not
scripturally supported I'll give you
another example John 3:
33-35 he who has received his testimony
has certified that God is true verse
34 for he whom God has sent speaks the
words of God for God does not give the
Spirit by measure the father loves the
son and has given all things into his
hands you see all three mentioned the
Father the Son and the spirit mentioned
there but the Bible continues not only
in the gospel of Matthew and the Gospel
of John but also Paul the Apostle to the
Gentiles brings us up in Romans chapter
14 verses 17 and
18 verse for verse 17 in Romans 14 for
the kingdom of God is not eating and
drinking but righteousness and peace and
joy in the Holy Spirit for he who serves
Christ in these things is acceptable to
God and approved of men right there in
the passage the Holy Spirit Christ and
God so you see the Bible is continual on
this reiteration that the the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit are unified so
when the Bible says the Lord our God is
one God the Hebrew word there is in
unity mhm
not in separation in unit we are one
that means if the president and the vice
president makes a decision that's one
decision right if the secretary and the
vice president and the president makes
that decision represents them all and so
that's the kind of Oneness is talking
about but the Hebrews made it very clear
when they said the Lord our God is one
God they understood they understood the
Dynamics of the godhead they did not
misunderstand that you find here let's
look at another one in John
14:16 I will will pray the father I will
pray the father who's saying that Jesus
is speaking I will pray the father and
he will give you another helper or
another comforter that he may abide with
you forever Jesus is praying to the
father for the comforter to come and
then last couple of ones acts 10:38 how
God anointed Jesus of Nazareth with the
Holy Spirit and with power God anointed
Jesus with the Holy Spirit and with
power lastly we're going to one day get
a chance to see God's face Revelation
22:3 and 4 and there shall be no more
curse but the Throne of God and of the
Lamb shall be in it and his servants
Shall Serve him and they shall see his
face and his name shall be on their
foreheads so God one day will get a
chance to see him unbroken communion
when we are Immortal and when we are
Incorruptible thank you and it's amazing
how people don't believe in and that's
just the tip of the iceberg what is the
trinit Aran well there's when you say
the word Trinity you have to understand
what school is coming from because like
the word rapture we can say the word
rapture but we mean the visible literal
second coming but that means something
different in the Evangelical world so
you got to find out what school of
thought is coming from it's huge yeah
there's many that don't believe the the
god father father son yeah yeah thank
you so much for that okay let's go to
our next question Pastor James here we
go this is an interesting one okay
should we tell people who recently lost
a loved one that they're not in heaven
but in the ground until Jesus returns
how can we explain resting in the grave
to a grieving loved one who doesn't
understand wow you know the state of the
Dead is one of the most beautiful and
truly apologetic teachings of scripture
you know so many people uh get this
teaching wrong and so many people either
worry about their loved ones burning in
Hell or suffering in purgatory or up in
heaven looking down on this world of sin
and suffering you know many Christians
uh try to comfort people with the idea
that the loved ones are in a better
place right uh but it's confusing it
really is confusing you know because at
the funeral they say uh they're in
heaven looking down on us uh while at
the grave site they'll say rest in peace
are they in heaven looking down on us or
are they resting in peace you know what
is the situation and it's and it's
confusing because we're not following
the word of God and so we just kind of
throw our hands up in the air and we
hope for the best you know in first
Thessalonians chapter 4 the Bible
answers your question directly so let's
just look in there in 1 Thessalonians
chapter 4 we'll begin with verse 13
we'll read all the way through Verse 18
and then we'll back up and we'll just
take a little summary of of what the
Bible is saying here Paul begins in
verse 13 and this is in relationship to
the stay of the dead he says but I do
not want you to be ignorant Brethren
concerning those who have fallen asleep
lest you Sorrows others who have no hope
for if we believe that Jesus died and
rose again even so God will bring with
him those who sleep in Jesus for this we
say to you by the word of the Lord that
we who are alive and remain until the
coming of the Lord will by no means
precede those who are asleep MH for the
Lord himself shall descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of the
Archangel with the trumpet of God and
the dead in Christ will rise first then
we which are alive and remain shall be
caught up together with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air and
thus shall we always be with the Lord
and here's the final phrase therefore
comt Comfort one another with these
words that's the directive from the
Bible I can't do any better than that we
can't do any better than that notice the
two answers that this text brings to
your question answer number one verse 13
but I do not want you to be ignorant
Brethren concerning those who have
fallen asleep or who have died the word
sleep is used in the Old Testament and
the New Testament for death that's right
and so God Paul is basically saying here
God is basically saying here the Bible
is basically saying here no I don't want
you to be ignorant should we tell people
well the Bible says I don't want you to
be ignorant but why don't doesn't God
want us to be ignorant what's the reason
or the purpose of the motive are we
going to go into a funeral or some kind
of um family get together where people
are are G and sad and just slam down the
state of the dead and tell them they're
all misunderstood and they're all
confused and they're all wrong is that
going to comfort them no well we have to
we have to weigh that right and most of
the time we've got to be aware of the
situation and Circumstance that we're
going into God's purpose is to comfort
us right with these words but at the
same time he doesn't want us to be
ignorant so you got to balance there and
we can't give you an answer to say this
is what you need to do every single time
but you need to take the word of God you
need to go to God in prayer and you need
to let the Holy Spirit leads you to in
your situation your circumstance as to
what to do very good didn't you used to
believe that you die and go to heaven oh
yeah absolutely I believe that I was
raised Catholic I believe that oh yeah
was it strange for you to it was such a
comfort it was such a comfort to to
understand what the Bible taught because
I used to think the ghost around here
evil my people up there what's going on
am I going to go to hell when I it was
such a comfort it was so powerful and it
was such uh uh peace to my heart to see
God's character in this way he knew the
best way to deal with the state of the
Dead you know he he's done the best this
is the best option that I can imagine
anyone could come up with you don't go
immediately to hell or immediately to
Heaven you'd see your friend suffering
you'd be burning down there and then
pulled out judg and then thrown back in
no God's got the best solution you rest
and the grave sleep is just a second of
time and the next thing you know is
eternity that's right or judgment
whichever one it is right they're not
down there looking at their watch they
don't know know anything they're not
looking at their no it was a blessing
thank you for that that's right yes with
the twinkling of an eye we'll be all
Chang right amen thank you okay here we
go Pastor John will Sodom and gomorah
and the four other cities be brought
back to be burned again they were
already judged with fire and Brin Stone
was already upon them Tony from Canada
this is from well no uh very directly no
Sodom and gomor and the four cities will
not be brought back again to be burned
again that judgment has already occurred
that means god Vindicated his
righteousness on the sinfulness of those
cities as is the case in the anti-
delvian world they're not going to be
brought back to drown again God's
judgment was Final there but what we
have to understand here is there's a Day
of Reckoning for all humanity and I'm
glad that the topic that you just
addressed was about death let me just go
go ahead and lean into that with John 5:
28 and 29 because both classes of every
one of us is going to be in one class or
the other and I could actually say four
but in this particular I'll point out
two because we're talking about the
resurrection we're talking about those
things that are already passed John 5:
28 and 29 do not Marvel at this the
Bible says for the hour is coming in
which all who are in the graves will
hear his voice and come
forth those who have done good to the
resurrection of Life those who have done
evil to the resurrection of condemnation
so those who have done evil in Sodom and
Gomorrah will come out to give an
account for what that evil was and the
clear the clear understanding of that is
in 2 Corinthians 5:10 for we must all
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ that each one may receive the
things done in the body according to
what he has done whether good or bad let
me make a very important Point all works
don't save us but our works is an
indication of our saving relationship
with Christ just ification has nothing
to do with our works but sanctification
cannot happen without our works it's the
work of a lifetime developing the
Christian character to become like
Christ those who claimed to know God and
did not live in harmony with that will
have to give an answer for that so Sodom
and gamorra its inhabitants will be
brought back in the Judgment not to not
to say oh we're back in Sodom and
gomorra no those cities are not going to
be brought back but everyone will appear
before the Judgment seat of Christ and
the end result will be Revelation
22:1 he that is unjust let him be unjust
still he who is filthy let him be filthy
still he who is righteous let him be
righteous still he who is Holy let him
be holy still righteous and holy filthy
and unjust the only two categories no
third category and then the Bible talks
about this and judgment Revelation 20
and: 12 and I saw the dead small and
great standing before God pause for a
moment are the people in Sodom and
Gomorrah do they die yes yes of course
everyone who has died will have only
two choices of resurrections matter of
fact two designations of resurrections
they're not a grave saying well let me
see which one the pick no once you die
the Bible says is it is a point is it is
appointed unto men wants to die and
after that the Judgment all right if
you're in Christ there's no fear in the
Judgment perfect love casts out fear but
revelation 22 and Revelation 20:2 says
and I saw the dead small and great
standing to be before God and books were
opened and another book was open which
is The Book of Life and the dead were
judged according to their works by the
things which were written in the books
and then what's the end result
Revelation chapter uh 20 and verse
14 then death and Hades or the
grave were cast into the Lake of Fire
this is the second death now let me
qualify what happened in Sodom and
gomorra that was the first death which
everyone that is involved in sin
experience whether you die in a car
accident or whether you die in the
Flames of the destruction of Sodom and
gomorra that's simply the first death
but we must now come forth in the
Judgment 2 Corinthians 5 and: 10 and
then that judgment talked about in
Revelation is the great white Throne
judgment the second Resurrection yes but
those as James read in first
Thessalonian they come forth in the
resurrection of life so the answer is
yes they'll come back but not the cities
they must all give an account MH wow so
true and in Luke 17 you could read that
about the days of Sodom are we living in
these days today it's worse it's it's
Global it's not just located in Sodom
and gomorra it's all over the world
we're living in the Sodom wow the sin of
Sodom and gomor is the sodomy and oh my
anyway let's move
on okay Pastor James this this is your
five minute question so here we go
Pastor James you previously stated that
Jesus suffered the second death is that
true and if so how is it possible I
thought the second death is the Lake of
Fire reserved for the devil and his
angels please explain this is from James
all right James well this is a very good
question very challenging question
because the Bible doesn't specifically
say that Jesus died the second death
that specific phrase second death is
only found four times in all the Bible
and all four times are in the last book
of the Bible the Book of Revelation two
verses describe those who will not be
hurt by the second death and two verses
describe those who will experience the
second death which is the Judgment of
God against sin now the first two verses
are in Revelation 2:1 and Revelation
20:6 these are positive references is
promising Believers that they will not
be hurt by the second death and it will
have no power over them which is praise
God hallelujah amen the final two verses
found in Revelation 2014 and Revelation
218 are the two verses that describe the
second death as the Lake of Fire so
there is one verse of the four in the
second death in The Book of Revelation
second death verses that actually
describe the second death as the Lake of
Fire so let's read these two verses
verse 12 and I saw revelation uh Chap
20:2 and I saw the dead small and great
stand before God uh and the books were
open and another book was opened which
is The Book of Life and the dead were
judged out of those things which are
written in the books according to their
Works verse 13 and the Sea gave up the
dead which were in it and the death and
Hell lived up the dead which were in
them and they were judged every man
according to their works and death in
hell were cast in the Lake of Fire that
is death in the grave as John shared I'm
leaning Into You John cast in the Lake
of Fire this this is the second death
and then verse 8 of Revelation chap 20
but the fearful 21 actually the fearful
the unbelieving the abominable the
murderers the hor mongers the sorcerers
the idolators all liars shall have their
part in the lake which burns with fire
and brimstone which is the second death
so the context of these two verses
describes the second death as a judgment
against sin and those who refuse to let
go of sin that's really important
because the question we need to ask is
did Jesus experience the Judgment of the
second death described in Revelation
2014 and Revelation 218 in other words
was Jesus judged according to our works
was Jesus charged as an unbeliever a
liar a murderer was Jesus did Jesus
experience the weight of the sins of the
world in our behalf and the answer to
that question of course is yes now it's
an important one and it's important to
note that the second death is described
as a lake of fire in Revelation 20 but
it's also described in other other
places in the Bible and a lot of people
don't know this and it's different in
these other places than the Lake of Fire
let's take a look at some of those
verses for example we noted that only
the Book of Revelation describes the
second death but the Book of Revelation
borrows from the rest of the Bible so
it's not unique in its teaching the
Revelation is not teaching something
unique that's not found anywhere else
the Bible refers to the second death
with terminology like cut off or cursed
or Forsaken and all of these terms are
used used in the Bible to to describe
the second death experience we can read
that in Matthew 24:41 for example or
Psalm 88: 5 and8 for example or Daniel
chapter 9 and verse 26 for example
secondly forsaken is another biblical
term referring to the second death
experience Jesus Christ in Psalm 21
verse1 uh was prophesied as feeling
forsaken of God my God my God why hast
Thou forsaken me why have you cut me off
right so
God is describing the second death
experience in these phrases in the Old
Testament and even in the New Testament
like in Matthew
27:46 which all also describes those who
are going to be cut off or Forsaken and
of course Paul talks about those who
won't be forsaken of God in 2
Corinthians 4 and verse 9 a lot of
verses here you'll have to look at them
here's another one point number three
cursed is yet another biblical phrase
denoting the second death experience
according to Matthew 25:41 and Romans 9:
3 Christ the Bible says was made a curse
for us Galatians 3:13 this is because
Christ became sin for us second
Corinthians 5: 21 so the wages of sin is
death Jesus became sin for us he
experienced or tasted that death Hebrew
chapter 2 and verse 9 Isaiah 5310
through2 teaches that Jesus poured his
soul unto death the death he tasted was
not just physical it was physical mental
and spiritual he felt cut off he felt
forsaken he felt cursed he was unsure if
he would come forth from the tomb but he
was VCT Victorious over that second
death experience by faith and the
promises of God and this is what the
Bible teaches so if we look at all of
this we see a bigger picture than what
we see in Revelation chapter 20
concerning the second death in the Lake
of Fire we see the Bible is throughout
the Bible giving us this these different
phrases that describe that second death
experience and indeed applying them to
Jesus Christ Our Savior who tasted death
for every man that's right wow that was
well said in John 3:16 right for God so
loved the world he this beautiful you
know and there's two there's this first
death the first death is the natural
death isn't it mhm and the second death
is Lake of Fire Lake of Fire that's it
okay what you always say honey Live Once
Die Live Once Die Twice live once no
born Once Die Twice born twice maybe die
once right
yeah well you sleep actually so you
don't die EX in that sense right
thank you thank you well said all right
Pastor John it says Pastor lomacang I
heard a sermon you gave regarding a
visit to London where the calendar
begins on Monday as the first day of the
week how do Sabbath Keepers continue to
honor the seventh day with calendar
changes this is from Sandra North
Carolina okay thank you for that Sandra
you know I remember that very well in
the hotel when we were
when we were registering I saw behind
the the clerk there and um Monday the
first day Sunday the last day yeah and I
said excuse me and she said well that's
that's correct yeah now that's correct
in England but that's not correct
scripturally and that's not correct
globally and so what's happened is the
metamorphosis of the changes made by men
or what some societies are affected by
but as a Christian we we don't go by the
calendars that men change an altar you
have the Gregorian calendar and you have
the Julian calendar the two great
changes in history but neither of them
put Sunday as the last day they always
had Saturday as the last day of the week
and to get this very clear as a
Christian the Bible makes it very clear
which one is which I'll go to Luke
chapter 23 and it surrounds the death
burial and resurrection of Jesus Luke
23:
54-56 speaking about when Jesus was
crucified and taken off the cross that
day was the preparation Luke 23:54
and the Sabbath Drew near so notice this
and the women who had come with him From
Galilee followed after and they observed
the tomb and how his body was laid verse
56 then they returned and prepared
spices and fragrant oils and they rested
on the Sabbath according to the
Commandment so the preparation day
before the Sabbath so let's look at
something I'm going to kind of come at
you at an angle here then now they're
resting according to the Commandment
which one the fourth Commandment in the
Luke 24:1 now on the first day of the
week very early in the morning they and
certain other women with them came to
the tomb bringing the spage which they
had prepared but they found the stone
rolled away from the tomb and the body
of Christ was not there now here's the
confusion that happens in
England they celebrate Easter also yeah
so when they celebrate Easter do they
celebrate Easter on the first day which
is a resurrection which they all believe
all throughout Europe the Pope has
Resurrection service on Sunday yeah and
they all know that that's the first day
of the week according to scripture if
you want to talk about confusion that's
the best answer for confusion for those
of us who are beholden to the word of
God we are obligated to keep the
Commandments of God and this is where
Jesus says in vain they worship Me by
their tradition what are they doing
they're teaching for doctrines the
Commandments of men so when when you say
well Sunday is the last day of the week
you've got to delete this story in Luke
23: 54-56 because it clearly outlines 3
days the
preparation and then the Sabbath is next
and then the first day of the week well
those who honor the resurrection know
that the resurrection and the Sabbath
are not the same day but the day that's
referred to as the Sabbath is the day
before the resurrection so if the
resurrection is the first day what day
is the Sabbath the seventh so now you
have to ask yourself the question those
of you that are in England is the
Sabbath and the Resurrection Day the
same day scripturally no that's why the
Bible is pushed aside and tradition is
looked at in its place and that that
happened in 1565 when Pope Regio
declared that tradition is above the
Bible so those of us so those of you
that look at tradition as higher than
the Bible you could follow whatever you
want but for those of us that believe
the Bible says let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter fear God
and keep his Commandments for this is
the whole duty of man Ecclesiastes 12:
13- 14 we honor the Commandments of God
therefore how do you keep the Sabbath
you say to your employer I follow the
Bible and if you have religious freedom
he cannot obligate you to violate your
religious freedom amen wow thank you so
much we got to move right on okay okay
Pastor James uh it says James rafy
recently answered the question about the
spirit of Prophecy I understand that
this gift was manifested both in the old
and the New Testament and also in the
remnant church but aren't there people
with the gift of Prophecy in today's
world this is from
Jenny hi Jenny thank you for that
question good question this promised
gift of the holy spirit is bestowed on
the church we're told in 1 Corinthians
12:1 as the spirit Wills that means it's
up to God to give the gift it's not up
to us to claim the gift necessarily some
people will say I've got this and I've
got that well it's up to the spirit to
give the gift just starting with that
thought you know knowing the history of
the Bible and the remnant church as we
do we recognize that not all whom God
calls to experience the gift actually
willingly accept God's call for example
Jonah was reluctant to be a prophet for
God when the word of God came to Jonah
we're told that he ran off Jonah 1: 1-3
he ran off to Tarsus from the presence
of God and we know Moses was also
reluctant to be a mouthpiece for God
Moses said in Exodus
3:1 who am I that I should go to phah
and that I should bring the children of
Israel out of Egypt balam actually tried
to misuse the gift of Prophecy for
monetary gain in 2 Peter 2: 15 and 16 he
forsook the right way and went after the
wages of unrighteousness we're told in
second Peter 2 and then of course we
understand that this quotation is given
in the context of a a conflict against
or a warning against false prophets
coming into the church second Peter
chapter 2 is warning about false
prophets coming to the church so yes
there's this genuine gift of Prophecy
but then there's this false counterfeit
prophecy that Satan's going to try to
bring into the church when we put this
all together we realize that Ellen White
God's Prophet to the remnant Church also
struggled to accept the call herself
after two other men had actually failed
to prove faithful to the responsibility
so yes the gift is given by the Holy
Spirit as the Holy Spirit Wills to edify
God's people in today's world it's given
uh for the purpose of edifying or
growing the church but given the
Biblical history and the more recent
Adventist history it is not a gift that
we can expect many people to be willing
to even bear or to Bear Faithfully
without using it in a way that is not in
harmony with the Bible so given these
many warnings regarding false prophets
this is definitely a gift that will be
closely guarded by God and will be
counterfeited by the adversary and of
course any manifestations of the gift
today need to line up with the biblical
marks of genuine a genuine prophet and
fall in line with all the inspired
messages that God has already given us
in his word and through the spirit of
Prophecy all right thank you okay let me
ask this last question really quickly
okay pastor John I have problems
understanding the unrighteous servant in
Luke 16 1
through3 what did I consider wrong
however it seems like it was being
praised can you explain it for me yes in
a nutshell this is about stewardship and
Allegiance there was a faith there was a
steward that decided he was going to do
transactions his way yeah and when it
was found out he was no longer allowed
to be a steward because he was not
Equitable in his handling of the
businesses that was put into his account
he was cutting back on some holding back
on others and those who were benefiting
from it commended him for that but later
on he was called into account why have
you done this and the issue was are you
Faithful in what God puts into your
account so the story ends when you look
at that as a whole Soliloquy on
faithfulness and how you handle what God
has put into your account and for those
that are concerning with Mo Money and
its benefits they'll do things to
benefit themselves but the Lord says in
verse 13 of Luke 16 no servant can serve
two masters for either he will hate the
one and love the other or else he will
be loyal to the one and despise the
other you cannot serve God and Mamon so
when you are being tested in financial
areas be faithful to God Amen don't let
the desire for financial gain cause you
to be an Unfaithful Steward and that's
why the blessing that comes to us is
because of faithfulness and stewardship
and particularly tithes and offering
time Talent testimony and treasure it's
about faithfulness and allegiance to God
in all areas of your life that's right
it's always more blessed to give and to
receive in every part of your life amen
well we're going to take a short break
and we're going to have a few closing
thoughts from these two wonderful guys
we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
3abn.org
word welcome back we have a few closing
thoughts from Passage John and Pastor
James Pastor James just on the second
death question you know if Jesus had
only died the first death or he
experienced the first death then we'd
all be subject to the first death
exactly thankfully he died the second
death for each one of us that's right
amen and uh simply to the point whatever
the Lord puts within your will and
within your a sphere of influence be
faithful you could never out give God be
a faithful Steward in all that God has
given to you thank you I hope you
enjoyed this wonderful study remember
other books were given for information
but the word of God is given for
transformation have a blessed day in
[Music]
Jesus